trajectory beaucoup de morts bien sûr
toujours c'est tous les livres seront
mis condé fait je peux pas vivre sans
aller l'aller partout et puis dalida
marilyn c'est là surtout j'adore
regarder
enfin les aléas lecture heureuse elle
souffre plus aller bien et j'espère
qu'elle nous voit le ciel nouveau et
nous interroge mais bien la faute aux
électeurs de glace aussi aller belle
elle a une double importance parce que
ça c'est au fouquet's assez la main de
jean marais jean marie serre la main
gauche
vous avez acheté récemment au nom il ya
une vingtaine d'années d'avoir fait de
choses de lui voilà
m
ça c'est des cadeaux de fans sais pas
comment ils ont fait ça des pourboires
sont pas ces des fans ça qui vous en
voyez ça ouais ouais je souhaite dans
celle là c'est le père et son fils il à
50/50 petit ça doit d'ailleurs c'est
anthony dis donc à part la couleur des
cheveux j'ai pas beaucoup changé non 55
ans c'est dingue
j'adore souffrent tous là ça c'est vrai
que c'est allé quand on était à qu'un
débat voilà génial tu la vois la belle à
s'assécher la plume au vent de ma vie et
c'est ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
avec m retraités l'âge été vu faisant
exactement
mireille janot et celle là est très
belle tient j'adore ya rencontré cela
j'adore ces visconti et la callas j'ai
acheté cette photo en vente je sais par
où elle est belle elle est vraiment
belle
il y en a des photos ici un bordel ici
me sylvie carrière bobo un beau bordel